[Applause]
this is the craziest thing I think
people realize it's like my Jordan's ego
I feel like he's humble
I feel like Jordan even as huge as his
ego is he's actually humbled because
everybody is getting paid because of
Jordan now he changed the world son
yes he changed the world I'm just
talking about basketball players I'm
just talking about LeBron James and
talking about all of his like Scottie
Pippen I'm talking about Charles Barkley
all of his friends and all that kind of
[ __ ] like you could act like you're his
contemporary he's looking at you and
he's like I made this CBA increase the
salary cap three times I did everything
that you get is because of me you're all
eating off of me not only is the Bulls
organization everybody around you is
eating off of me you got sneakers
because I got a sneaker that was I was
gonna respond to it the one they said
like LeBron got Tristan Thompson 80
million dollars no Jordan got Tristan
Thompson 80 million dollars Jordan got
LeBron a billion dollars from Nike
Jordan made every dollar you make
possible mm-hmm
like I think magic had sneaker a sneaker
and I think bird had a sneak yet but I
don't know who the [ __ ] Chuck Taylor was
was he a basketball player some white
guy probably was he I don't know I was
Taylor the third assumption like some
[ __ ] right so it's like what Jordan had
the signature shoe and now you see this
signature shoe yeah right this is
something that happened to put
perspective into the amount of money
that's been generated I think last year
Jordan Brand made 3.6 billion dollars
Nike basketball made 1.8 billion what
some Jordans lasting legacy this is
thing people realize we'll remember
Jordan as a basketball player his
lasting legacy will be Jordan brand it
will be basketball sneakers the kids now
that are watching this documentary son
the kids now that are watching this
documented kids in college don't even
remember Kobe's heyday I think people
realize like you have Kobe and the
Lakers Kobe and the Lakers with Shaq the
three-peat in happened in 2000 20 years
ago if you're in college right now you
don't remember Kobe's greatness with
Shaq yeah you remember the Lakers
dynasty you weren't alive we're alive
for a dude how [ __ ] nuts is this so
Jordan brand is going to be the legacy
of Michael Jordan not Jordan the player
[Applause]